A classical computer performs operations using
classical bits, which can be either zero or
one.
Now in contrast, a quantum computer users
quantum bits or qubits.
And they can be both zero and one at the same
time.
And it is this that gives a quantum computer
its superior computing power.
There are a number of physical objects that
can be used as a qubit.
A single photon, a nucleus or an electron.
I met up with researchers who were using the
outermost electron in phosphorous as a qubit.
But how does that work?
Well, all electrons have magnetic fields,
so they are basically like tiny bar magnets.
And this property is called spin.
If you place them in a magnetic field they
will align with that field, just like a compass
needle lines up with the magnetic field of
the earth.
Now this is the lowest energy state, so you
could call it the zero state or we call it
for the electron, spin down.
Now you can put it in a one state, or spin
up, but that takes some energy.
>> If you took out the glass from your compass
you could turn the needle the other way, but
you would have to apply some force to it.
You have to push it to flip to the other side.
And that is the highest energy state.
In principle, if you were so delicate to really
put it exactly against the magnetic field,
it would stay there.
>> Now so far this is basically just like
a classical bit.
It has got two states, spin up and spin down,
which are like the classical one and zero.
But the funny thing about quantum objects
is that thy can be in both states at once.
Now when you measure the spin it will be either
up or down.
But before you measure it, the electron can
exist in what is called a quantum super position,
where these coefficients indicate the relative
probability of finding the electron in one
state or the other.
Now it is hard to imagine how this enables
this incredible computing power of quantum
computers without considering two interacting
quantum bits.
>> Hello.
>> Hi.
Now there are four possible states of these
two electrons.
>> You could think that, well, that is just
like two bits of a classical computer, right?
If you have two bits you can write zero, zero;
zero, one; one, zero; one, one.
Right?
There is four numbers.
But these are still just two bits of information.
Right?
All I need to say to determine which one of
the four numbers you have in your computer
code is the value of the first bit and the
value of the second bit.
Here, instead, quantum mechanics allows me
to make super position of each one of these
four states.
So I can write a quantum mechanical state,
which is perfectly legitimate, that is some
coefficient times this plus some coefficient
times that plus some coefficient times that
plus some coefficient times that.
So determine the state of this two spin system,
I need to give you four numbers, four coefficients,
whereas in the classical example of the two
bits, I only need to give you two bits.
So this is how you understand why two qubits
actually contain four bits of information.
I need to give you four numbers to tell you
the state of this system, whereas here I only
need two.
Now if we make three spins, we would have
eight different states and it could give you
eight different numbers to define the state
of those three spins, whereas classical it
is just three bits.
If you keep going, what you find is that the
amount of equivalent classical information
contained by N qubits is two to the power
N classical bits.
And, of course, the power of exponentials
tells you that once you have, let’s say,
300 of those qubits in what we call the folient
angle state, so you must be able to create
these really crazy states where there is a
super position of all three angles being one
way and another way and another way and so
on, then you have like two to the 300 classical
bits, which is as many particles as there
are in the universe.
>> But there is a catch, although the qubits
can exist in any combination of states, when
they are measured they must fall into one
of the basis states.
And all the other information about the state
before the measurement is lost.
>> So you don’t want generally to have as
the final result of your quantum computation
something that is a very complicated super
positional state, because our cannot measure
a super position.
You can only measure one of these basis states.
>> Like down, down, up, up.
>> Yeah.
So what you want is to design the logical
operations that you need to get to the final
computational result in such a way that the
final result is something you are able to
measure, just a unique state.
>> That is not trivial.
And it is essentially ... I am kind of stretching
things, but I guess it is to some degree the
reason why quantum computers are not a replacement
of classical computers.
>> They are not.
>> No, they are not.
They are not universally faster.
They are only faster for special types of
calculations where you can use the fact that
you have all these quantum super positions
available to you at the same time, to do some
kind of computational parallelism.
If you just want to watch a video in high
definition or browse the internet or write
some documenting work, they are not going
to give you any particular improvement if
you need to use a classical algorithm to get
the result.
So you should not think of a quantum computer
as something where every operation is faster.
In fact, every operation is probably going
to be slower than in the computer you have
at your desk.
But it is a computer where the number of operations
required to arrive at the result is exponentially
small.
So the improvement is not in the speed of
the individual operation.
It is in the total number of operations you
need to arrive at the result.
But that is only the case in particular types
of calculations, particular algorithms.
It is not universally, which is why it is
not a replacement of a classical computer.